the cost of college is skyrocketing
outstanding student loan debt this
morning tows more than 1.4 trillion
dollars and it is growing today's
installment of our ongoing series issues
that matter focuses on the presidential
nominees plan for education we look at
everything from pre-kindergarten to
college we spend more money per pupil
than anybody else and were at the bottom
of the lists we're going to change that
we're bringing it locally we'll be doing
it with love and smarts believe me
they're also going to strengthen
education at every level starting with
universal pre-kindergarten education we
will rescue kids from failing schools by
helping their parents send them to a
safe school of their choice I want good
schools with good teachers in every
single ZIP code in America and common
core bum-out
I have always supported national
standards I think we need better and
fewer tests that are used for what tests
should be used for I'm going to work
with Congress on reforms to make sure
that if universities won access to all
of these special federal tax breaks and
tax dollars paid for by you that they
are going to make good-faith efforts to
reduce the cost of college and student
debt and to spend their endowment on
their students rather than other things
that don't matter and I'm going to make
public colleges and universities
tuition-free for any families making
less than a hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars a year
students should not be asked to pay more
on their loans than they can afford and
the debt should not be an albatross
around their necks and a borrower's work
hard and make their full payments for 15
years will let them get on with their
lives we're going to change the way that
debt works we're going to bring down
interest rates and we're gonna let you
pay it back as a percentage of your
income and if you do certain public
service or national service jobs we're
gonna forgive a lot of or all of the
debt in return for you doing that
joining us to discuss this issue is
Margaret Spellings she was education
secretary under President George W Bush
spellings helped implement the No Child
Left Behind Act she was also part of the
effort to start a national conversation
about the future of higher education
spellings now serves as president of the
University of North Carolina she
oversees 17 campuses in nearly 225
thousand students good morning secretary
president I know general yeah we know
each other from from from the Bush
administration and I was out there on
the campaign trail when education was a
frequent topic absolutely by the nominee
and while we just heard the two
candidates talking about education is
this an issue do you think that's been
front and center in this campaign
probably not as much as it was then but
that I think clearly it's an issue that
speaks to Millennials that speaks to
middle-class families and to women and
so to the extent they talk about it I
think that's they who they help is
listening and you've said in your
opening you know UNC your inaugural
address is you took over the presidency
there that we can't allow a child's
future to be dependent on a zip code
exactly many cases it it absolutely and
that's our new responsibility and
American higher education is to make
sure it's available and accessible for
many many more people than ever before
first-generation low-income and minority
to do we do then yeah well we make
college affordable for starters and one
of the things that drew me to North
Carolina is it is a very affordable
state and relative terms but it's still
a struggle financial issues are often a
barrier I was heard you say that that
kids take too long getting through
school they do what do they do what I
mean is students need to get in and out
of college as quickly and efficiently as
possible in four years optimally as
opposed to six I mean our completion
rates are often based on six-year rates
and you know time is money and so to be
very efficient about what you want to do
your pet your trajectory to get through
college so that you're not spending more
time than you need to and spending more
money than you need to taking courses
that are you know extraneous now the two
candidates have different positions on
Common Core Hillary Clinton says that
she supports the national standards
Donald Trump says he will get rid of
Common Core do you think it makes sense
to start from scratch on common core
these are state standards this is a
state-led effort that began with the
governor's and have been embraced now by
43 states the reason that makes sense is
because it allows technology and
textbooks and teacher with development
all sorts of things to be done and in a
more efficient way in a more cost
effective way it also helps people like
military families who are moving around
from place to place you know Nora who
you know lose time and get off track
because their tape there's no coherence
in the standard since it so it makes a
lot of sense there's a lot of talk in
this campaign about Millennials and how
they'll vote a big issue for them is
student debt yes absolutely should we do
well obviously the candidates have
talked about putting more money at the
federal level you know buying down
interest rates for those current debt
holders but also I mean mrs. Clinton has
talked about free college using federal
funds Sanders yes absolutely and you
know as as you know talking about free
college is not free nothing is free so
it's all the question about who's gonna
pay the individual the state or the
federal government and so again I think
you know people need to have some skin
in the game and you know we need to make
sure that that people are showing up
ready to do college work do it
effectively and efficiently and you know
have as little debt as possible but
there are three schools at the
University of North Carolina where you
where the tuition is $500 wilber yeah
per semester for tuition if you live in
state yeah how do you subsidize that
well it's $2,500 for out-of-state
students we will have three institutions
Western Carolina Elizabeth City and
Pembroke who beginning in the 1819
school year will have $500 a semester
for tuition that will obviously draw
growth in the student population raised
the quality of the student population
and it's a great deal you know this
legislature the North Carolina
legislature has done something we've
asked them to do okay here's the
question since you've been education
secretary what federal power can a
president really have in affecting
student inequality or teacher inequality
or education inequality well that varies
with you're talking about federal policy
we're a pretty big investor at the
federal level largely around financial
aid Pell grants and student loan
programs work-study those sorts of
things I mean big big many billions of
dollars as opposed to k12 where we're a
nine percent investor so really you can
do a lot especially if you're targeting
that a those financial supports to those
that mean do you think there should be
universal pre-k well I think what we
need to do is make sure that the pre-k
we have largely headstart which
obviously is an income base need-based
it's the right kind of pre-k that it's
you know sets the table for good
learning that there's pre reading skills
and so forth that and so I think we need
to get pre-k right before we expand it
there's also debate as to whether
everybody should go to Cosman will they
be better off in community colleges and
technical schools well that's that's the
question it's not about a baccalaureate
degree it's about everyone needing some
post-secondary education whether it's a
technical education a certification
program so when I say college I think
mrs. Clinton means this also that we're
talking about some level of
post-secondary experience at least two
years just like we used to think of a
high school diploma as the ticket to the
American dream
now that's college some college what's
the most important education issue that
we're not talking about Margaret that
you think we should be low expectations
I mean I think we you know if the
President Bush used to talk about the
soft bigotry of low expectations the
idea that half of our minority students
you know can read on grade level or half
of our minority students get out of high
school on time in in disadvantaged
communities it's outrageous and if half
the school lunches were tainted we'd be
on fire but you know it's we accept this
under performance this under achievement
and we can't
there should be can't they do overs but
you believe that President Bush would
have been a far different president if
he hadn't gotten bogged
well and that's what he campaigned on I
know yeah so you know compassionate who
knows but you know he did a lot in the
domestic agenda that notwithstanding so
alright Margaret Spellings good to have
you at the table I love your glasses
oh thanks and they're looking where'd
you get the burro ready there ah thank
you very much